what up guys welcome to the just hurry
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down where I have guests on from
all different walks of life but my very
favorite guests are ones that hate
feminism as much as I do now Rachel
Wilson has been on the show before she
was a fan favorite you guys loved her so
um I decided to have her back on Rachel
the author of occult feminism uh a New
York Times bestseller I just made that
up it's an Amazon bestseller and Amazon
I don't actually know anything about
about the book awards I was like but I
felt like you got something but actually
you know
a a modern day genius you know what I
mean yeah I will take it I will take it
thank you welcome to the show Rachel
thanks for having me back I'm happy to
be back so
um last show can we start tell the
people where they can find your book
first because it is a good book oh
thanks you find the book on Amazon it's
there's Kindle audiobook I even have a
Spanish version now and you know
hardcover paperback and then
um I'm gonna have a new book coming out
this fall too so keep an eye out for
that one it drops
um if you are in a place where you can't
or don't want to use Amazon you can
always find me on social media if you
want like a signed copy or something I
can get you one of those so
and tell them where they can find you
Twitter Youtube yes I'm on Twitter at
Rach for patriarchy so it's r-a-c-h the
number four patriarchy because we're for
the patriarchy around here and I have a
YouTube channel it's just at Rachel
Wilson
that's where you can find me so my first
question tell the audience why is
patriarchy good because when we hear
patriarchy it just has like a negative
connotation
yeah yeah the women's studies
Department's got a hold of that word and
propagandized it and used it as like a
turned it into a very derogatory term
that's instantly people associate it
with oppression right the evil
patriarchy always keeping the women down
men throughout history just got up in
the morning had their breakfast and went
how can I keep the women down right like
that's just how they've always been
they're just evil men the evil men just
got nothing else to do except try to
figure out what they can do to hurt all
the women you know
um but really all it means is that so
the like the root word just means like
father like fathers should be the head
of things right fathers are the head of
the household men are the fathers of the
nation and should run the nation in the
church they should uh run the church it
just means that men since they have the
most responsibility also need to have
the proper authority to go along with
that responsibility so they're
responsible for taking care of women and
children who cannot care for themselves
and defend themselves against foreign
enemies or or you know go out and keep
the power grid running or things like
that as we know you and I talk all the
time about how men are the ones that run
and build the infrastructure therefore
if they're going to have all that
responsibility for the survival of
humanity then they also should have the
appropriate authority to go along with
that that's all that patriarchy means
but it has turned into this like dirty
word of like of the evil men just want
to like enslave the women so I'm trying
to like take the term back really yeah
and that it was kind of like I have to
tell you when I first decided if
everyone knows my favorite topic women
shouldn't vote
when I first like um came to that
conclusion I kind of said it as a joke
because I was like we really don't make
good decisions
should we vote should we return our
rights guys and I swear I was just
kidding but then I just kept thinking
I'm like
well how does it make sense that they do
all of the work they pay the most most
of the taxes they do
pretty much all the infrastructure jobs
I know we got a couple female cops that
really do their damn discs but we keep
seeing clips of them just getting
destroyed and I don't mean to laugh
because it's really sad like to those
cops but it's like you know the women
that think they're doing infrastructure
jobs it's really just kind of like a a
women hire you know like a just like uh
to make us feel better yeah it's like uh
what do you call it like an affirmative
action hire
so what do you what do you think of
women in politics should we be
completely banned from politics
personally I think we should and um I
think we're gonna get into some stuff
today that will support our arguments
here okay but me personally no I don't
want women to be involved in politics
um this anti-suffragettes at the turn of
the century had some really great
Arguments for why they did not want to
be involved in politics and didn't want
women politicians running things either
um and there's a lot of good reasons for
that I mean
if you're gonna put women in positions
of power then things come to mind like
okay if you can run the country why
shouldn't you also be drafted if you're
going to send men to war why shouldn't
you also be on the front lines and then
if women are on the front lines fighting
battles that gives the enemy a distinct
Advantage because they're going to
kidnap the women or do things to the
women in order to get all the men to
rush in and save them and things like
that and this has been like known
through all of human history that if you
put women on the front lines in a battle
it's a massive disadvantage to do that
so that's like one good reason but there
are many well and it's so funny women we
just get these silly ideas
you know and I I feel bad sometimes
because you know I I do talk about women
in like tongue-in-cheek a little bit and
like I I think I think you're a genius I
think you're so smart but as a group
it's like we're idiots
like the collective decision making I'm
like I don't know guys
I'm smart at history you know I love to
dig into history books because I'm very
nerdy and I like to find like really
obscure Source material that other
people probably don't care to go through
because let's be honest like if people
are wondering how did Rachel find all of
this history of feminism and like the
other academics aren't writing about it
well number one the only academics who
go into this field of study go into it
because they're already feminists but
number two men don't really care they
don't want to read about what first wave
suffragettes were doing or what they
were writing about they don't care so
I'll do it but that does not mean like
if if something goes wrong with the
computer or the drain backs up in my you
know bathroom or you know something like
that I have to go get my husband so it's
like it's nice women can do things it's
not that we can't do stuff we can do
stuff but we're still not men and we
still need men to enable us to like I
couldn't be here talking to you right
now if my husband didn't help me set up
all the tech and everything and I know
women are going to say well I know how
to to set up my tech I know how to set
up my cam and my mic and all this stuff
I was like yeah but you didn't build the
software you didn't build the actual
like circuit boards you didn't solder
all those tiny Parts like women aren't
mining the lithium that makes the
batteries for our phones so it's the
it's the modern technological world that
men built that gives women this illusion
that we're the same as men and that we
don't need men anymore if if that went
away tomorrow feminism would just be
gone and I'd be I'd be out of a grift
Pearl I'd have no more grip left correct
well and it's funny too because it's
like all right Diane you plugged in your
road Caster Pro
it's like there are coal miners out
there are you gonna are you gonna mine
the cold and you know I had this other
thought that men are just kind of better
than us in every way and you know I know
that's kind of a mean thought but maybe
you could help me I have been trying to
find something for months that women are
better at but when I found out we were
more likely to kill infants than the
elderly I was like guys
we couldn't we couldn't
we couldn't like do the nurturing and
then I found out that the top like only
fans models
um guys are making more with AI chicks
and when they manage us so I was like
guys
we can't even sell sex that's like our
one thing
no I mean historically that's why pimps
existed right too to protect even even
the prostitutes need protection from men
from other bad men and things like that
so it's an well the thing about it is
that it's an inescapable truth of
reality there's nothing you can do about
it men are always going to have the
Monopoly on force and any rights that
women have are only going to be an
illusion because they are granted to us
by men who have to enforce those rights
like and people my husband's done dozens
of debates on this nobody's beating him
I just had a debate where a woman was
insisting to me that you know women are
more peaceful that if women were in
power in Rand countries that that things
would be more peaceful so I brought out
all these statistics about how one women
are in charge like let's say in a
women's prison or a juvenile facility uh
they tend to be far more likely to
perpetrate abuse of all kinds on anybody
that they have power up over
um so well and well and you know what I
realized I I realized they fake all the
stats now and they it's like it's so
there's so much um
propaganda and all the schools that they
can just make a study that says you know
like women are think it's so sexy when
men do chores I'm not gonna say who
quoted that Adam preached Destiny idiots
but it's like it's like they start to
like convince you that water isn't wet
yeah and what I realized is I'm like you
can look at this on college campuses
look at the difference between frat
houses and sorority houses
sorority houses will like they will
sleep with each other's boyfriend
they'll be conniving half the girl and
the guys okay maybe they get like hazed
a little bit but like they take it in
their brothers for life like they'll
come back 20 years later and be best
friends or the women will still remember
I know what [__] I hated in high school
so she calls me that 40 years ago and
it's never been okay we don't let things
go yeah Tara well you might you might be
surprised to find out that actually all
of feminism is based on nothing but lies
and propaganda which is really like why
I do all this writing and why I do all
this research because when I found this
out for myself I was mad I was like so
this whole nonsensical system we have
now where all the moms are like going to
work and sending the babies to daycare
to just get raised by different other
women and uh we're splitting up families
the mom can just kick the dad out
because she just decided to that when
she was just in a mood that morning and
just kicked him out all of this crazy
system we have right now that's ruined
everything was all based on total lies
so like if you go back to people don't
know there was a first sexual Revolution
everyone thinks that happened in the 60s
that was actually the second sexual
Revolution but can I guess yes I guess
was it in the 20s yes it was in the
rooms
yeah I'm getting good at this stuff
you're getting it you're getting it okay
and the reason that this happened was
because when World War one ended in 1918
that same year they began passing
suffrage for women in England and then
two years later in the United States
they passed suffrage for women and so it
was this new woman right this new
liberated woman and there was a big
post-war economic boom as well so we
have flapper girls coming in right the
flapper girls with their short dresses
they cut their hair short for the first
time
um and they would party and smoke and
drink and the very first forms of birth
control started to become legalized
prior to that
um there wasn't much and what there was
was illegal wait really yeah in the like
what kind of birth control was legal so
you had like uh cervical caps and
diaphragms they weren't very good they
were like
um like just rubber like not not even as
good as what we have now but they did
tend to work the failure rate was fairly
High compared to the stuff we have now
but they passed a set of laws in the
late 1800s in the United States called
The Comstock laws which made it illegal
to buy and sell
um contraceptive methods of any kind
like
um you know primitive forms of condoms
and things like that through the U.S
mail so a lot of the first wave
suffragists uh who wanted to get birth
control out there got in trouble for
selling and promoting these things and
they would get prosecuted under Comstock
laws and put in jail or fined one of
those people was Margaret Sanger the
founder of Planned Parenthood
and you're gonna love this so when she
when she decided to become a socialist
she joined the Socialist Party in New
York and got really into feminism she
had been a nurse for a short time prior
to this and supposedly
helped assist with some births okay this
is how the story went and so she they
kind of picked her like New York was the
center for socialism in the United
States and some of the more prominent
well-known funders of socialism thought
oh an ex-nurse okay we'll we'll put her
in the Forefront and have her be kind of
a mouthpiece for like fighting for
women's right to contraception behind
her like who's funding her
uh it was mainly like uh the wealthy New
York socialites it was like rock
Rockefellers were her main funder far
and away but she did have a few others
early on who probably nobody would know
their names but they were just uh
wealthy New York socialites who liked
the idea of socialism for a number of
reasons and wanted this sexual
Liberation because
what's the point of giving women the
vote they just we just really want
women's input on politics no no that's
not why they wanted women to vote at all
it was more to emancipate them from the
home uh get rid of marriage get rid of
the nuclear family phase all that stuff
out and the reason behind that the
reason they wanted to do that is because
at this time we shifted from like having
a religious based society to having like
a scientific Society based on Evolution
so all the elites who were graduating
from the prestigious universities are
talking about Evolution they didn't know
about genetics per se like they didn't
hadn't discovered DNA yet but they did
know that you could
modify the population based on breeding
practices and this was called Eugenics
right selecting certain traits selecting
against birth defects things like that
so these Elites these scientific Elites
wanted to create like a more resistant
population remember we're just coming
out of world war one and they want to
create you know better soldiers uh
Stronger children that can resist like
starvation and things like that so
they're thinking we can start using
selective breeding processes to make
stronger more resistant populations this
is where you get the idea of the Uber
mensch the super soldier that you'll
often hear people talk about in Germany
so so a couple I have a couple questions
about this yeah do they say like the
Rockefellers and these Elite socialists
do they write this down yes yes and
where do you like find that information
so you can go to the Rockefeller
archives and find old press articles
um books that were written articles that
were written about what the Rockefeller
Foundation was doing back in the 1920s
and 30s uh that's where I go that's kind
of my go-to thing but there's other
people who have written it there's um an
auto uh authorized biography of the
Rockefeller family by Collier and
Horowitz it's a huge book really thick
book
um where the Rockefeller family comes
out and says that they did these things
because they see it as a positive
they're like yeah we were totally
responsible for women's Liberation isn't
that great aren't we awesome aren't we
nice
um and we really pushed birth control
and we really pushed psychology the
Rockefeller family is responsible for
establish psychology which is women's
favorite weapon these days right
um so they were just very Progressive
and
um utilitarian so they weren't
didn't like communism because they liked
communism and they didn't like
capitalism because they liked capitalism
they were happy to use a combination of
those things whatever would get them to
where they thought Society needed to go
and mainly their interest was in
engineering a new Society
okay what was wrong with the society
they had
well that's a good question uh they're
it's not that there was anything
particularly wrong with it other than
the fact that this is the first time in
history that you have no more monarchies
you have nation states you have you know
England and France and the United States
switching over to like a form of
democracy with universal suffrage and
they see this as okay we're the richest
one of the richest families on Earth we
have this new money and we have
tremendous influence if we want to we
can set up non-governmental
organizations we can set up we can Lobby
the government for things we want and
they had this very Progressive vision of
like a one world government and uh
sexual Liberation and really
depopulation and this is because of the
influence of the malthusian league there
was like this big movement that came
with Darwinism to again like
engineer the population and they're
thinking oh we can wipe out all the
birth defects right we can make birth
defects a thing of the past we can make
handicaps like non-existent and but in
order to do that we have to reduce the
population down to like this manageable
number but then doesn't it when you
reduce the population too much isn't
that like where all the inbreed because
okay
I was I I was I was trying to understand
the thought process behind eugenics yeah
and I was I was researching
I think I can talk about them in this
context they're getting in trouble
lately but but I was researching like
Hitler's like point of view right and I
think he said he he felt like the Aryans
were Superior the Aryan race and I was a
little confused as to who Aryan was but
I think it's like German Iceland and all
of them and I know Sanger was like
associated with them like she was yeah
and
um so
like but wouldn't okay because I'm
thinking like wouldn't that cause like
inbreeding for one and two I wanted to
know if I would make it because I'm
Irish too but Irish is like below right
Aryan right
so I was like yeah yeah you're 50 50. do
you get through or no well that's the
thing is that these were kind of newish
ideas so this is all based on the work
of Thomas Malthus who around 1800 came
up with this he did this um like
experiment where he observed the
evolution of flies in a jar because
flies only live a few days before they
die they have a very short life cycle
and he figured out that you could like
genetically like through selective
breeding change the traits that you
would find in the fly right so I mean
maybe they had Rosie lofty goals of like
oh they're suffering in the world right
kids are born with horrible deformities
and people are born with like mental you
know problems and things like that and
if we can just figure out how to breed
those things out you know we can
engineer the human race to perfect it
they really had this belief that it was
their job to steer Evolution
well because I'm just thinking like my
my dad's side they they had 13 kids and
I don't I don't know one of my uncles he
passed away but he was like the fifth or
something he was he was like mentally
not you know he was like
I don't know if you're allowed to say
[__] now but he was and yeah and but
at the end
um my dad was like the second youngest
and he was so smart so it's like I don't
I don't understand how they would like
come to that conclusion because I feel
like in families I think I can I think I
can explain that so at this time like I
said they didn't know about DNA they
didn't have
um they didn't know about chromosomes or
anything like that so they're looking at
it differently they're looking at it as
not understanding that there's something
called epigenetics and epigenetics means
okay you're born with a certain genetic
code but it's the environment around you
that determines which genes are turned
on and which genes are turned off and it
really shapes you uh into the person
you're gonna be in fact epigenetics is
responsible for like 80 percent of how
you turn out so even though there are
some people who are born with like
horrible birth defects and everybody
would agree that's bad right but but
these other traits in human beings
they're trying to like you know they're
trying to select for higher intelligence
they're trying to select for resistance
to disease things like that they didn't
understand the role of epigenetics in
that so they got some pretty wild ideas
about you know we have to wipe out
um anyone who's a mixed race we have to
get rid of anybody who had a mother that
wore glasses or a father who you know
got rheumatic fever and now he has a
limp or something like anybody who had
any little thing wrong with them that
might not have been a problem of their
actual genes but just a problem of the
epigenetic pressures on their genes they
were gonna like get rid of everybody you
couldn't even make it if you had glasses
yes so I wanted to tell you today about
the British Margaret Singer because
you're in England you've got a lot of
people watching you from there so she
doesn't get a lot of love everybody
knows about uh Sanger and how she felt
about uh
let's say
minorities we'll just put it that way uh
she wasn't a fan
and but people don't know about Marie
Stokes who was basically the British
singer so she actually met Margaret
Sanger at a Fabian Society meeting and
decided she wanted to open up birth
control clinics in England and she was a
member of the Eugenics Society she
totally believed in Eugenics she thought
we should be breeding out everybody who
had anything wrong with them so like
you're born and you have a fever and
you're deaf in one ear sorry you don't
get to reproduce so again this not not
understanding the difference between an
actual genetic issue and epigenetics
like you get a fever when you're little
you get an ear infection that's not
treated and now you're deaf in one ear
so she actually disowned her own son
because he married a girl who wore
glasses cut him out of this yeah he
married a woman who wore glasses and she
cut him out of her will and and disowned
him and never spoke to him again that's
how extreme she was with this idea and
she's the one that started all the birth
control clinics in England and pushed
for women to you know not have children
like if there's the slightest thing
wrong with you you shouldn't be having
kids if you have more than one or two
children you shouldn't be having them
they had a lot of wild ideas back back
at this time they had ideas about like
if your head was shaped a certain way or
you know if you were
you know you had a certain body shape
even that they felt was undesirable
we're gonna get rid of you too so it was
like some of these people would get
really carried away with with what they
wanted to do right well and it makes
sense too because I learned about the
Chanel chick the other day
Coco shoes yeah yeah and she was
sleeping with everybody and I was like
how the hell did she do this and not get
knocked up if there was no birth control
but I guess there was a little bit yep
there was and well and there was a lot
of abortions at this time because uh
people don't know this this is one of
the big lies so Planned Parenthood lied
about a whole bunch of Statistics they
falsified numbers and figures knowingly
um my whole chapter 7 of my book is all
about this so if you guys want like okay
where is she getting these facts from
you want the sources it's all in there
but what they did they had several lies
the first big lie was Margaret Sanger
the way she got popular she fabricated
completely made up a story about this
woman who she says she assisted her with
a couple of abortions and the woman died
right and that the reason she died was
because she had to resort to these
unsafe illegal abortions and doctors
wouldn't tell her how to stop getting
pregnant
completely totally fabricated and a lot
of women still believe this they'll read
this old stuff when they're like going
for their women's studies degree and
they'll think this is real even though
all of our singers biographers have come
out and said look there's no record of
this woman ever having existed we've
searched and searched we have all the
documentation of the other things she
did we do believe this story was
fabricated those are her own biographers
who are sympathetic to her and think she
was good and they admit this was a lie
so this is the first big propaganda lie
that they began to build the birth
control movement on because what people
they do they tell us a sad story yeah
we just run to the polls yeah the women
at tugs on the women's heartstrings big
time this is why whenever there's like
an election cycle you start hearing you
know Democrats will be like the
Republicans hate old people and they
want to kill grandma and they don't want
to give the children free lunch in
school and then you know the Republicans
will come back with you know the
Democrats don't care about this group
and it's so they just it gets really
emotional and that's because the largest
voting block now is women has been since
the 80s so that's that's why the
political stuff is so overly emotional
now but people don't know that before
the legalization of abortion prior to
1973 when we got Roe versus Wade ninety
percent of abortions were performed by
doctors the rest were performed by
midwives this is big lie number two big
line number two is back alley abortions
and you will still hear this I'm sure
you've heard women say this where
they're like but before it was legal
women had to get these horribly
dangerous Bosch abortions and they all
died well guess what uh the founder of
one of the biggest Planned Parenthood
clinics his name is Dr Bernard Nathanson
he came out after his retirement and
said look we fudged all those numbers
okay we actually have really good record
keeping in the decades prior to the
legalization of abortion where we know
for sure for example in 1972 in the
United States only 39 deaths
from illegal abortion that's at 39 but
they used a number that was like 10
times bigger than that they would say it
was like 3 900 or it was over four
thousand so they would
and he says in his Memoirs we knew these
were incorrect numbers but we kept using
them anyway because we knew it was good
propaganda
so uh
yeah the after the legalization of
abortion we actually ironically saw
deaths from abortion go way up way up
like tenfold they skyrocketed wow
because because now at this time in the
70s we're having one and a half million
abortions a year so even when it's being
done in a Planned Parenthood Clinic the
death rate's gonna go up because the
rate of abortion goes through the roof
so it's this idea people have that well
we have to keep it legal because
otherwise it's too dangerous it's
actually the statistics don't reflect
that now don't shoot the messenger
everybody I know this is a Hot Topic I'm
just telling you that they themselves
admit yeah we completely lied we
falsified a bunch of numbers we made up
fake stories and this is how we got
things legalized and this is how we got
things passed through
so that's how they did that
wow that's a that makes perfect sense
sad story women run to the polls yeah
and I'm I'm curious because I was
thinking about this I was like
so many women get abortions now so I was
kind of wondering
I I guess they're Pro are there more
pregnancies now or before I was thinking
if women used to have five kids it was
probably before but I just kept thinking
like we have all these abortions like
right left and right like there has to
at least be more like
unplanned pregnancies or something like
that
that's just big why number three
actually you're I love how your little
brain works because you're always asking
the quest the obvious questions that
people don't ask because they're
programmed by the propaganda not to ask
it but you'll ask it you'll be like wait
that doesn't compute I'm trying to think
this through right well because like
okay because
it's like once you recognize the
propaganda you can kind of identify it
and it doesn't make sense that we are
having more promiscuous sex with more
people and there was like if we were 85
percent married like a hundred years ago
now we're all divorcing our husbands and
just you know screwing Bob down the
street like I just can't imagine that
like women were perfectly responsible
and took our birth control on time
yeah so this was big lie number three
the the way that they got everybody to
get on board with birth control because
all of this was extremely unpopular
especially among women prior to women's
suffrage women were more conservative
than the men because they kind of knew
intuitively that like hey our our value
what makes a good life for us is
convincing men that hey we're going to
be a virgin on our wedding night we're
gonna give you babies you know and we're
going to be good Mothers they kind of at
that time felt like this is a really
essential truth of like what makes us
valuable as women so if you do all this
is probably not going to be good for us
they weren't surprisingly they were not
too dumb to figure that out right so the
big sell for the birth control pill even
though so many people were against it
when it came out was well this will
eliminate the need for abortion if we
give everyone the birth control pill
then everyone will just have babies when
they want to and it'll be by choice and
it will eliminate these on wanted
children it'll eliminate the need for
abortion and again that's not what we
see that's not what we see at all I mean
you can get birth control now over the
counter without a prescription right so
why last year did we still have 73
million abortions worldwide why are we
still having uh this is a crazy
statistic and this is
um
I have the source here oh this is this
is from the world health organizations
they say that 61 of all unwanted
pregnancies end in abortion still to
this day and a whopping 29 of all
pregnancies end an abortion
20. wow nine percent of all this is from
the World Health Organization what they
can gather on you know based on how many
pregnancies they think there are they
say so again don't shoot the messenger
it's not me making this up this is the
World Health Organization saying 29 of
every pregnancy that occurs ends in an
abortion so much for this idea that the
birth control pill is going to eliminate
the need right isn't this bizarre and
yet we see like 88 90 of women are going
to be on birth control in their lifetime
so why are they all needing
abortions uh but it is because now the
rate of like promiscuous sex outside of
marriage has exploded compared to what
it was prior to birth control well yeah
it's crazy like when I found out that I
mean
let's just assume the women are liars
they're lying then they're lying now and
they said 85 percent of women were
virgins on their wedding nights I'm like
okay let's double the non-virgins let's
just say they're Liars let's say it's 30
we're non-virgins right that's still the
majority
virgins and I'm like wait now and I
looked it up it's like four percent I
mean I've seen between like four the
highest ten that I've seen but I've seen
more closer to four or five or six
percent and you don't even know out of
those six like how many were fat how
many you know you know what yeah that it
was just a result of them not really
having a choice about it yeah like
so you know I'm like
so how did we go from that
to this
and it's so crazy because it's like
I've heard girls say they just wanted to
get it over with having sex
like this is the this is the culture
yeah it's the culture and it's so the
first sexual Revolution they push all
this birth control propaganda and
they're telling everybody there's this
epidemic of overpopulation which is
still something that I hear people say
all the time people still think this
even though Elon Musk is coming out all
the time and telling everybody no no no
we've been in birth rate decline for
over a century and this is the other
crazy thing about Margaret Sanger and
Marie Stokes and they're lying is that
they were already seeing the birth rate
drop off a cliff before birth control
because of women's lib because of all
the feminist propaganda leading up to
suffrage we already saw like this
massive Decline and it's because women
are going to work and women were going
to school and you know they go to
college and get a degree and they're
like well I don't want to give up my
career for babies right so we already
see the birth rate down to like two and
a half births per women when it had been
seven a century prior to that when did
when was it two and a half what year uh
I think it was like 1910
wait really because when I looked it up
I thought it was five you're probably
right I just I think it was I think it
was like five live births it depends on
birth stats are a little tricky because
it depends uh if you're talking about
per woman or per thousand or whatever
but the average woman in 1800 had like
seven children and then I think the end
of the 1800s it was down to like
five-ish like you were saying but then
by the time suffrage passed only a
couple decades later it had gone way
down even more it had dropped even
further so
um they were already kind of lying
because they were still fear-mongering
everybody with this idea that uh you
know we just have way too many people if
everyone's gonna starve because there's
not enough food
um and that just wasn't really true you
could say there was a problem of
logistics of like getting food where it
needed to go or things like that there
was there was issues with disease it's
not like life was perfect prior to
suffrage but all the things that
feminism said it was going to do to fix
that it didn't fix it it actually made a
lot of things worse so
um they lied about
they lied about the birth rate to begin
with they're scaring everyone to death
that there's too many people who are all
going to starve they it's the same thing
you hear right now with climate change
where people are like if we don't do
something in 10 years the whole planet's
gonna die we're all toast it's over they
were doing the same thing in the 20s and
30s to get birth control passed they
were telling everybody if we don't get
this done by 1950 half the world's gonna
starve to death like there was massive
propaganda going on then and then again
in the 70s so in the second sexual
Revolution they repeated the same scary
propaganda tactic of we're all gonna
starve to death we're going to kill the
planet there's too many people when that
really wasn't happening there were only
you know around a little bit above
replacement coming out of world war one
and we had just seen this massive die
off of people in World War one so
um what happened was they got abortion
legalized in Russia first in 1919 I I
think it was and that was a woman who
got this done she was the first
um Head of State in any government
really the highest position of any
female the first one her name was
Alexander collentine she got the
Bolshevik Russians to pass a law making
abortion free and legal and paid for
right up until birth in Russian
hospitals and within 10 years they had
three abortions there for everyone live
birth
wow and Stalin came to power and said ah
this is not good we're gonna get wiped
out by you know Europe or China or
somebody if we continue this so he
reversed that and made it illegal again
but Russia still has one of the highest
abortion rates in the world
um it's the propaganda there was so
insane that I think it's just lasted
it's just continued that's really
surprising because I've heard women in
Russia are like you know I I have these
countries that I label like the better
than us like this is where the men go
when they're sick of us the Western
women and Russia's on there so I'm
surprised that it's so high well there's
been a lot of pushback like there's been
a because uh Russia's been traditionally
an Orthodox Christian Nation but the
Bolsheviks tried to destroy the church
and wipe it out and they were somewhat
successful with that for several decades
so it's taken a long time I mean they
were still under communism until 1989 so
it's taken a long time for them to
recover but now socially that is what
they're trying to do they're trying to
uh you know kind of go to something more
conservative to encourage the birth rate
to go up to discourage abortion they're
trying to get the family put back
together but Russia was really decimated
by this propaganda under the Bolsheviks
Stalin for all of his bad points you
know not saying staling good but I'm
saying he did have at least the
foresight to see that this was a bad
idea and was not good for uh you know
the future of Russia to have this crazy
women's lib and they had a lot of sexual
Liberation there they had a huge sexual
Revolution they were very accepting of
like divorce way before anyone else and
and other alternative Lifestyles we'll
call them
um until Stalin came in and and tried to
like clamp down on that but it took a
long time and they're still kind of
recovering but here in the west we've
just completely doubled down on this
stuff so I mean Marie stopes in England
she was unfortunately very successful
with what she wanted to do as far as she
had two birth control clinics that were
extremely popular you're gonna love this
too because she was married right her
first husband he went to Canada for
business and while he was away she went
to the court in England and asked for a
divorce knowing that he wouldn't be able
to get back in time to contest it and
she lied to the court and said that they
never consummated the marriage and that
was her grounds for divorce she knew he
couldn't come back and say anything so
they did Grant it to her when he got
back to England he found this out and
his quote that he said was that she was
so promiscuous that like he said I we
did consummate that happened but this
woman is wild and she will just sleep
with everybody said I could have I could
have satisfied her if she was like any
normal woman
so we see this like this idea that uh
you know the promiscuous women were the
original feminists I find that over and
over in my research they always are
divorced they always leave the husband
they leave the kids right so she marries
her second husband for the mainly for
the purpose of money to help fund her
birth control clinics and her like books
she wrote she wrote a book for women
teaching them how to have sex instead
crazy lady but her her Legacy in England
is that you guys have something called
the Marie Stokes International now it's
just called the MSI because this woman
was such
she it's just called MSI uh reproductive
choices now they changed the name
because she is so associated with the
Eugenics movement she wanted to you know
like I said she disowned her own son for
marrying a woman with glasses
crazy lady and this entity still exists
and it's actually expanded into Africa
so this was the big thing right we're
going to expand into India and Africa
any of the places that are still having
a lot of kids and we're going to get
their birth rate down
now MSI received seven and a half
million pounds from Phil Harvey who is
the founder of the Adam and Eve like sex
toy porn company
um and they provided five million
abortions in 2019. so it's found it's
funded by a guy who runs a big a huge
International porn operation and this
these are the people who want these
things right so
I mean when we're thinking about birth
control and we're thinking about Family
Planning right they always give it a a
nice term they don't want to call it
like you know killing babies they don't
want to say
um preventing motherhood they don't want
to say what it really is so they'll call
it stuff like Family Planning uh and now
we're to the point where we're well
below the birth rate and they're saying
that in the next three years now half of
women of childbearing age are never
going to have a child in the West
pretty terrifying stuff
so
why is it when women get that because I
heard
even before abortions women were still
killing our kids like I heard that was
in the 1800s like I heard it was really
underreported yes because you know I
mean I I just think men have always kind
of swept stuff under the rug for us and
so it's like why is it when we get the
choice like why do we kill our kids like
aren't we supposed to be nurturing what
like what is that
well I think the women who do that are
the women who have this control thing
right where it's like I need to be in
control I want Power for myself and is
it true that I I have five children
myself is it true that they will hold
you back from things like having a
career or being promiscuous basically
what do children hold you back from
stuff you probably shouldn't be doing or
don't need to be doing like sleeping
around having different boyfriends a lot
of times it was if the women are having
an affair
right
um and they get pregnant it's like I
better go take care of this in case this
baby comes out with red hair you know or
something that's gonna make my husband
suspicious like it would reveal the
affair
um other times I mean it's
I know people will probably watch this
and they'll think yeah but Rach uh you
know would you want to have to be a
woman with no access to birth control
and you have like 12 kids whether you
want to or not
um there's hardships involved with large
families no one's saying there's not
however you have to think of it in
context and balance it with okay what's
worse the hardship of having a large
family or the hardship of having a
Birthright solo that we're looking at
like population collapse which is going
to mean things like interrupted Supply
chains not enough food for the people
who are still around because you need
more population is actually better to
solve problems like
um starvation so if you go read books on
this is why again Elon Musk not saying
he's like the perfect guy or anything
but he is a smart guy and he does
understand Logistics and he understands
systems and he knows that if we have a
population crash it's going to cause
massive problems worldwide we're already
seeing it in Japan and Canada places
where the birth rate's been really low
for a long time they're like offering
people money to euthanize themselves
once they get too old or if they have
depression or if they have like a
chronic ill illness they're like what
would be the point of getting money like
you're dead right well it's like we'll
give it to your family you know you're
basically you're worth more to your
family dead than you are alive uh we
don't have enough people to take care of
you you're old you're not producing
anymore so let's just end it here you've
had a good run like when it's over for
you um think of the future Generations
it just so like if you're worried about
things like people having enough food if
there's not enough people to produce the
food and get it where it needs to go the
starvation is going to be worse like it
used to be prior to industrialization so
we live in an industrialized Society now
we need to at least maintain the
population I don't think we'll ever get
back to a point where we're going to
have too many people because you can't
put the you know you can't put the
toothpaste back in the tube there's
always going to be some women who are
going to want to be career women and go
to university and not have kids because
they want to have you know champagne
brunch and travel and
post to their Instagram or whatever
because it's easier to be a dog mom than
have kids and that kind of thing but
you don't want it going so far the other
way that you're looking at what we're
looking at now or you're looking at what
Russia was looking at in the 20s where
it's like oh [__] we're about to be
wiped out because no one is having kids
now everyone just wants to be
promiscuous and not think about the
future nobody wants to invest in the
future I heard and I don't know if it
was Iceland or some other country over
there that they would encouraged people
to have sex on the first date
they don't even I don't think they even
have I mean like they're probably one of
the closer societies to being a
matriarchy they're still not but it's
something closer to that really yeah I
think they a lot of Icelandic people
don't actually even get married they
cohabitate like they'll have a kid or
two and they'll live with a guy but the
women take their dad's name and then it
gets translated into like so if your
dad's name was Bjorn thornson your name
would be Thor's Daughter or something
like that so they they actually feminize
the last name and then I think that a
lot of times they don't take the man's
name I could be wrong on that but based
on what I've seen that seems to be what
it's like
okay so what so they basically
the Sanger
and the England check and I used to
their name I forgot what it was they
basically stoked Stokes yeah they lied
to women and basically faked all these
stats yep and then what what happened
after that so then
um the Rockefeller Foundation gets
involved and they
they're doing a lot of research in
Germany at this time about hormones and
they're thinking that they can come up
with some kind of contraceptive pill
based on synthetic hormones but they
need funding right so they send Sanger
over to meet with a scientist there his
name was Gregory Pinkus she goes there
in 1951 and meets with him and he shows
her his research and he's like I think
we can get this done but we need a lot
of money well she knew somebody who had
a lot of money another feminist woman
right her name was Catherine McCormick
and Catherine McCormick has a wild story
um that you guys might think is kind of
interesting she got rich by marrying
Stanley McCormick who was the heir to
the International Harvester Fortune the
big tractor company oh so she married
him and shortly after they got married
he had some kind of mental illness he
had like an obsessive compulsive
schizophrenia type of thing going on and
he was a compulsive
um fapper he was a
he couldn't stop touching himself he
compulsively touched him so yeah yeah he
was crazy so he he even built like a
harness for himself to sleep in so that
he couldn't do that to himself
um and his wife was obviously disturbed
by this so she had already gone to
Germany and gotten the help of the
Premier psychiatrist in the world at
that time and these are I don't want to
use the um naughty word on YouTube but
they're Germans and this is you know so
um these scientists from Germany were
they came and diagnosed him and they
said yeah he's schizophrenic he's he's
probably not fit to manage his fortune
so they gave control of his fortune to
Catherine McCormick
now Catherine McCormick uh
and Stanley Stanley's brother was Harold
McCormick and he married Edith
Rockefeller so this is how we get the
Rockefellers coming in and then we've
got the McCormick's with their
International harvest report they
already have money oh yeah yeah yeah so
Edith Edith the Rockefeller from
Rockefeller oil he uh he was a big oil
magnate of the 1800s became the richest
man in the world and then the family
just you know the fortune just grew as
the century passed so he married a
Rockefeller woman Stanley's brother
Harold did so Edith Rockefeller is a
total crazy person uh she was into Union
psychology and had her own psychology
practice why I told you women love
psychology man let me let me figure out
how to manipulate how your mind works
um but she had her own practice and she
was a crazy person who I mean I think
she was crazy maybe you guys don't but
she was into in astrology and Eastern
mysticism and reincarnation and she
claimed to have been King tutankhamen in
a past life okay these are the people
we're dealing with Super Saiyan yeah
it's totally normal
um so I had a lot of past lives too yeah
yeah you were Cleopatra in a past life I
bet
I want to be Michael Jackson
perfect
[Music]
so these are so we've got the chronic
masturbator guy who needs to harness
himself so we can stop touching himself
and then we've got the crazy Rockefeller
lady who married his brother and she
thinks she's The Reincarnation of King
Tutankhamun these are the people
Margaret Sanger was friends with and she
went to them and said look we can
probably get a birth control pill so
that everybody can just be as
promiscuous as they want and at least
they won't get pregnant and we can
revolutionize the world with this thing
so they gave her millions of dollars to
get this done 35 million dollars which
at that time is like oh it's a lot of
money so they invest and they actually
do end up creating the very first birth
control pill and they had a hard time
getting it to be socially accepted a lot
of like the Catholic church was not a
fan the more
um you know conservative Protestant
churches were not fans and women were
very suspicious they were like a way to
minute
it doesn't seem super safe for me to
just take pills full of hormones that
are gonna prevent me from getting
pregnant but it was again
sold as completely safe and why because
they did a bunch of Trials on the birth
control pill in places like Puerto Rico
where people are poor like they always
like to test their stuff on poor
indigenous populations so they go to
Puerto Rico and make a whole bunch of
women sick and infertile and and have
all kinds of no way yeah to to get in
trouble for stuff like that
well because at that time
there weren't a lot of people who were
going to object you know what I mean and
there wasn't the internet so it wouldn't
get widespread you can go back and find
news articles about this from like the
40s you can go back and find where they
were like oopsie uh shouldn't have maybe
done that but it's the same way that
they got away with like the Tuskegee
experiments uh there was a massive
Tuskegee experience
the United States military did uh a
totally illegal research project to
figure out the effects of syphilis
because there was a lot of syphilis
among servicemen in the first and second
world war and they wanted to do some
research on syphilis but you can't
exactly
like it was very taboo you know you
didn't want to admit that you had it and
you just certainly didn't want to get
syphilis for the sake of science so they
took a a whole Fleet of Airmen
um in Tuskegee Alabama who were all
black and they told them they were
giving them a vaccine
okay but it wasn't it was syphilis and
they injected them with it and then they
tracked them and watched the progression
of the different stages and what
happened to them and they experimented
on them with treatments and things like
that of course this is all for the
greater good it's all for science you
guys science is very pure
um and they only have good intentions
that's how they came up with like
I'm assuming they got a vaccine for it
yeah yeah
but there's like a there's a very long
history that's why when the thing
happened in 2020 the first thing I said
to my husband was like they come out
with one of those we are not taking it I
was just like nope nope nope right
must be nice
I mean this is when it's good to be a
history nerd right because you're
already gonna know that they're gonna
sneak something in there yeah um so they
did that and they got away with it and
then what they do so that what they do
when they get found out are caught doing
this they just go oh gee whiz we're
really sorry uh we didn't know it was
just a couple of Rogue scientists and
we're super sorry we got rid of them and
here's we'll give you each like a half a
million dollars in US right so they
don't really care they know that if they
get caught they'll just give them
settlement money and everyone will think
oh gosh that was horrible but you know
they fixed it they won't do they'll make
sure that doesn't happen again but it
just repeats so they did this with the
birth control pill they tested it on
populations who didn't really know
what they were getting didn't know that
this was experimental and might not be
safe
um and they perfected it that way and
got it safe enough now even to this day
right now when young women go to a
doctor to get a birth control
prescription they give it to you like
it's a vitamin I mean they give it to
you like it's a vitamin C tablet they
don't tell you all the possible risks
that it can cause infertility that you
might come off of it and not be able to
get pregnant that it might increase your
risk of cervical cancer I did a whole
show on the like risks of that with my
friend
um that's on my YouTube channel but
there are risks it's not a risk-free
thing when I um because I I barely was
on it I was only on it for like a year
and when I wanted to because I I
remember just you know I'm inquisitive
so I was like
I didn't really have any side effects
but I was just thinking this can't be
good I was like yeah I just feel like
this isn't good for for you like I'm
like you can't turn off no so and when I
got it like when I I went off of it she
was like are you sure
I was just like
yeah and she kept trying to convince me
to go back on I'm like no I'm okay
they also get Kickbacks for that so if
they can get you to do the depot shot or
certain pills the manufacturers give
them like a no way yep same thing with
uh vaccines
I have a nanny um and I don't know what
the vaccine was called but a couple
years ago it was like supposed to
prevent an STD Gardasil yeah and I
remember I I didn't get it but I
remember
um my my nanny ended up becoming
infertile because of it and it was it's
especially sad because she was literally
like
like she was a great Nanny and she would
have been a like fantastic like I had
nannies that I hated and her like I gave
her all my piggy bank money so she
wouldn't like leave like I was like
please don't go you know and because
like they used to have to go back to
Germany and she was just such a good
like she she was so good with kids and I
just think it's like the saddest thing
that she didn't get to have any because
of the shot she thought was supposed to
help her and she wasn't even crazy
either like she ended up getting married
like pretty young like she kind of did
everything on paper right
and you know you know when they came out
with Gardasil they wanted my oldest two
daughters were like teenagers at the
time and they pushed me so hard to give
that to them and I was like No And then
I came with you know my whole little
research book and I'm like asking them
questions and stuff and like putting
them to the question they were finally
like okay okay fine geez you know that's
kind of how I approached it because I
was just like no you're not going to
talk me into this nonsense and now there
I think there's a class action lawsuit
against it because so many women have
had
so many awful side effects from it some
have died like it's yeah well these
medical interventions are not risk-free
but they are promoted as though they are
and people aren't really given the
informed consent that they should be in
my opinion it's just my opinion I'm not
um please don't sue me and please don't
be mad at me I'm just saying what I
think you know well yeah it's almost
like they're running experiments on us
now when you think about it because I'm
like there's no way that all these new
like like I think Plan B is relatively
new
yeah and I'm like that one's like 20 15
20 years old and I'm like there's
there's no way this is safe
like I just can't
I I don't know the science I'm not
assigned yeah I didn't do well but I'm
just like and you know there's a girl
that came on my show that I mean she
took a lot but she took so many she was
infertile she took like three in a month
so like to be fair I'm like chick that's
a lot but you know
she's like what 17 18 when it happened
yeah oh my God and I was like girl three
like what do you do like you know but
it's like you don't really know the it's
almost like it's almost like they're
they're still doing experiments because
I'm just like there's no way you can
know the long-term side effects of this
stuff for sure yeah yeah that's the
thing is that it's
the reason I write this stuff and the
reason I do this research is to tell
people the truth about the propaganda
the lies that are sold to you because
um these organizations so when we're
talking about like the Rockefeller
Foundation The Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation these massive
philanthropic organizations that do
charity work okay if you they have
something called white papers white
papers are internal documents that are
written to tell the people in the
organization what the plan is they're
not meant to necessarily be released to
the public and they know that even if
they get out to the public nobody's
gonna read them and the media is not
going to report on it because the media
is specifically also controlled through
things like operation Mockingbird which
I think you just had Alex on and he was
talking about that that's all true you
can go to cia.gov and read all their own
papers it's just that nobody will so
nobody knows these things if you go look
at the white papers of the Rockefeller
foundation and the bill Melinda Gates
Foundation which I did they're huge
they're like hundreds of pages it's
boring you know but I was like I'm
taking one for the team so I can figure
out what's going on here when I wrote my
book and they say specifically in their
white papers that their goal now that
they've got the birth rate so low the
fertility rate is so low in the west and
they've convinced all the women that you
don't need babies you need a degree and
a career now we have to go to the last
two places that still have birth rates
above replacement which is India and
Africa and it says they are going to go
there they say this we're going to go
there and we're going to get the
fertility rates down we're gonna get the
birth rates down through birth control
and through abortion and we're going to
call it health care and we're going to
call it empowerment for women and girls
so whenever you hear these organizations
talking they're saying for women and
girls for women and girls for women and
girls what they mean is we're going to
make you infertile we're going to get
you access to this stuff so they know
what they're doing it's just that
Eugenics became deeply unpopular when
the populations found out about this in
the 40s and 50s they were like wait a
minute you want to sterilize all of us I
don't like that so they didn't end it
right they didn't end it what they did
is they figured out that they could use
soft language and Market it as
Healthcare Market it to people as well
yes it's empowerment for women and girls
that's what they so they know what
they're doing they're just saying you
know and they of course from their world
view from their crazy insane world view
this is why I talk about what these
people are into because these are freaky
people okay these are crazy people a lot
of times so from their worldview they
think what they're doing is good but
they know that we're not gonna think
it's good they know that Rachel and
pearl are gonna go uh I don't want to be
sterilized okay like I'm good on that
yeah no thing but they're like no no
it's no we're not sterilizing you we're
empowering you we're empowering you with
choices
so that's what they do and I did just
find um my birth rate stuff that we were
just talking about so this is in the 30s
that Sanger began fear-mongering about
the dangers of too much Reckless
breeding
and this was like her catchphrase and
the U.S birth rate had already tumbled
from 7.03 and 1800 to 3.64 in 1910 so I
was close but I wasn't exactly correct
wow um a decrease of half so we'd
already cut the birth rate in half
without birth control just with feminism
just with uh women's libraries and it
really shows that us women just believe
anything it's so crazy like I'm like
I'm starting to think they faked IQ
tests
there's some stuff out there on that
there's some stuff really because I just
came to this conclusion because I'm like
okay you're telling me all the richest
guys are men
we make the most idiotic decision like
even me I like to think I'm smart smart
but I I spent the first half of my 20s
chasing after a volleyball career
that made zero money or what like no guy
would logically think that through and
think that's a good idea like you know
the man that chase Pro contracts at
least like believe they're gonna go pro
you know what I mean there's at least
like a lottery Cash ticket at the end
there's no such thing in volleyball oh
no not really anyways yeah but you
probably heard a lot of stuff like
follow your heart and chase your dreams
and never give up and you know all this
all the stuff yeah yeah and so I just
start to like think I'm like
but the IQ test says the average woman
smarter than the average guy I just
started to think I just can't trust any
of these tests I just have to look in
real life
well if you if you look into IQ testing
data and the only reason I know some of
this is because when I was a kid I
scored off the charts on all this stuff
so they put me in like you know special
gifted kid programs and like I was
supposed to go to college you guys from
the time I was five it was like oh
you're going you're going to college
you're going to get a degree and you're
going to have a career that would make
so much sense for them to lie to us
about the IQ stuff well let's just
pretend that I'm some kind of Genius
okay let's just pretend Rachel's a
genius she scores super high on all the
tests in fact my I've told you this
before but my dad's favorite story to
tell everyone about me whenever there's
a party or something is about how when I
was in high school and I took our
standardized testing in my state I got a
perfect score
um even on the math and so they thought
I cheated and they made me retake it
with somebody like standing over my
shoulder and I still got a perfect score
but but here's the thing about that
right when we look at I IQ testing and
standardized testing men score much
higher on the stuff that I think you and
I would probably say counts things like
spatial reasoning so there's this um
problem that's kind of famous where they
take a beaker of liquid and they shift
it this way right and they go the the
problem will say okay it's filled to
here and if we turn it this way what's
the liquid inside gonna do and it's only
like 30 percent of women can figure that
out even like even to me I'm like duh it
would you turn it it would just still go
like this it would just the line would
be different but women have a hard time
with things like that they have a harder
time with logic which is why you don't
see very many women with philosophy
degrees or engineering degrees they
don't understand like spatial reasoning
um like certain types of mental things
that men are very good at that actually
build the world women are good at like
regurgitating facts and memorizing
things or like
um you'll hear all this garbage about
emotional IQ which I can't stand because
I know I know where all that comes from
and it's it's garbage it comes from
psychology departments with feminine
dentists who want to talk about
emotional IQ this is their big cope
right well well we might not be as good
in the stem Fields but we have a very
high emotional IQ and we're very
empathetic you know and it's like like
women are not
um empathetic to us no I mean they have
no problem like absolutely trying to to
destroy our lives and our self-esteem
and everything right yeah
but empathy in and of itself isn't even
a good trait like they find that too
much empathy actually like can be a dark
Triad kind of a trait where you end up
being
um like one of these crazy social
justice Warriors where you're like I
don't even care if the whole world Burns
as long as I feel like this is fair
right I care about fairness or I care
about someone I feel bad for and I don't
care if everyone else like suffers and
if it brings down the whole world so be
it because I want what I want right or
I'm gonna do whatever for this you know
this is why you see crazy people being
like we have to help you know
marginalized people and and if we have
to uh not use electricity and not have
air conditioning anymore and not drive
cars to save the planet and the Animals
the bugs right we have to save the frogs
so you can't drive a car and you can't
have electricity and you can't have air
conditioning we're all gonna live like
primitive tribal people because I have
feelings things about Mother Earth so
too much empathy is not in and of itself
any sort of win it's not a good thing
and this is why single mother households
are not great right because
so on the IQ test they basically added
feminine
things that women would like score well
on so like one thing I remember I scored
really well on the writing on the ACT I
was like I remember the valedictorian of
my class was a chick and she was out we
were in the same grade I was a little
competitive with her because we both
played volleyball whatever and in school
I never won and I was like that is my
one W I was like the writing section
yeah I they did do that's true I would
have to look into that to see kind of
who was behind that because I do
remember I'm older than you I'm like 17
years older than you I could almost be
your mama and when I was growing up they
did make this big switch where they said
oh well the job market of the future is
gonna require or universities now that
everyone's going to universities it's
going to require people to be able to
write essays now this doesn't make a lot
of sense when you think about it but
somehow they said we're all gonna have
to be able to write essays so they
switched everything from like multiple
choice or just like do the problem and
get the answer to like you have to write
an essay explaining how you got the
answer this kind of thing and yeah I
would think that men would probably be
like perhaps less good at that I'm not
sure like that's something that I'd have
to like look at it before I could say
definitively too I bet you they did that
makes perfect sense to me because they
made it more subjective with the essays
it makes it more subjective yeah and
women just naturally get stuff so they
just gave it to the chicks and you know
we're naturally good at that stuff
and I knew I knew I knew because I just
Rachel okay you don't understand I just
kept thinking I'm like I'm sorry I've
interviewed so many men and women and
when I it's so funny when you start red
pilling guys because it's like they just
start to not even if they're oh okay I
mean there's the ones that are too far
gone but for the most part even a more
liberal guy when you start to tell him
things that make sense they'll be like
oh
yeah oh yeah maybe women shouldn't vote
like you can kind of see that their
minds change women
um I'm not gonna say no women because I
have a whole series of me red pilling
women and sometimes but you have to
break it down and explain it like 10
times before they get it and they they
have the knee-jerk reaction to like
emotionally protect how they see
themselves that's the thing when I
debate women this is oh yeah when I
debate women this is what the issue is I
just had a debate with this woman who
now has become obsessed with me okay
I've had to like block her on everything
because now her mission in life is to
like destroy me because she was telling
me I was wrong about all this history I
made it up I don't know what I'm talking
about and I said she's like I know my
history I know the history I study and I
said okay let's do a debate so we did a
debate I shall act her I crushed her uh
it was quite humiliating and rather than
her going oh gee maybe I was uninformed
maybe I need to go back and think no she
like tripled down and decided it's her
mission in life now to somehow twist
things to somehow prove that I'm wrong
but she's not having any success doing
that and so now she just she started
following me everywhere and trying to
like say weird crazy stuff
um and it's like she's losing it she's
like losing her marbles over this
because I I just wrecked her world view
and women feel like very destabilized so
like but I thought I knew how the world
worked I thought I made all the right
choices based on how I thought things
are and now you're telling me that was
lies and propaganda and there's all this
evidence that the choices I've made
maybe aren't good and they can't so
rather than like go oh [__] you know I
should probably rethink this they just
cope ten times as hard and they just
triple down like the girls you always
have to kick out of your studio because
they just like lose it
let me yeah what happened to taking our
L's and moving on
you know our grandmas like let's not
pretend like our grandmas didn't take
elves but they took them they shut up
okay they might have bitched to their
friends but they at least made it quiet
okay and they moved on but it's like
sometimes you make the wrong choice and
you're just like you know
yeah I screwed up well I would tell my
daughters all the time if I did do
something stupid or I made a mistake I
would be like look uh you know I dad
told me to do this with the bank account
but that's not what I did I did
something else now it cost us like 300
it was a stupid mistake I made and I'll
tell them that on purpose so that they
can see the example of like a woman
being able to go you know what I was I
made a mistake my judgment sucked I
should have listened to Dad but I didn't
and now we're paying for it and so like
I'll just explain that to them because I
want them to see that a woman having
humility and saying I made a mistake I'm
sorry and learning from it is good it
doesn't mean people won't love me
anymore it doesn't mean my husband's
Gonna Leave me but it's like we tell
women you're perfect the way you are you
don't need to change anything think of
all the pop songs think of the fat
acceptance movement all these things we
tell women about how you're strong
you're a goddess slay Queen you're
amazing you don't have to change so if
they ever do make a mistake all that
programming in the back of their head
starts screaming no no no no no no you
can't make a mistake you're perfect the
way you are it like it will shatter
their view of themselves if they have to
go you know what I screwed up I had poor
judgment I made a mistake or you know I
did something I shouldn't have and I'm
sorry it's like modern women cannot do
that
they just can't do it yeah and it's like
I think that red pill
I think it's really helpful because when
you realize and I'll say to the audience
I say this tongue-in-cheek I know not
all but you know when you realize women
we just believe anything when you
realize as women we're just kind of
emotional wrecks and like we're kind of
a [__] once a month when you just
realize like you know that I'm supposed
to obey my dad you know when I'm at my
dad's house I'm supposed to obey my
husband my boyfriend it kind of makes
things like easier because it takes the
pressure off of you in making a decision
and you're just like you know what
whatever they do I don't have to stress
about the outcome because he he decided
it and it also really helps your
relationship with men and I'll give you
this one this one story this was
actually before I was even red pill but
my little brother Adam and I used to
like fight we would fight all the time
when I was younger we would just [__]
like we just we went you know he's my
little brother I didn't want to listen
to him you know I was just like I just I
thought but my little brother Adam
um is a really smart like he he's just
he's so freaking smart and he's also
like a really really hard worker and
growing up like we would kind of be
competitive with each other and this
wasn't like a red pill thing but it just
kind of happened I guess subconsciously
where I was like you know what Adam is
younger than me but he's better he's
just like he's a harder worker than me
he's smarter than me and it was so funny
because we used to fight all the time
and the day I just acknowledged he was
better and started listening to him and
this is like a brother-sister
relationship but even in there it's like
that wasn't like a conscious thing but
the day I just started listening to him
we had a completely different
relationship and it's like now I get
along with him so well he he's always
the one to help me with anything I need
help with
um and you know vice versa and yeah and
I'm I'm just like grateful that even
that was isn't really a red pill
understanding but I'm just like grateful
that happened because now I have a
completely different relationship than
if I had spent my whole life not
listening to him and just thinking I was
smarter than him and knew everything and
fighting with him you know yeah and I
think well that's that's the programming
that we're fighting with women right is
like
like I'm always getting myself in
trouble on Twitter because
conservative women right these like
political chicks the TP USA girls the
pantsuit boss babes they're having
women's leadership Summits I'll be like
why
why do we need a women's Leadership
Summit we don't need more female
leadership we need to restore male
leadership if you want things to get
better right and they will get mad at me
and it always comes out they show their
true colors that really they still
believe in this egalitarian nonsense of
we're equal to men well and they'll but
they'll cope and they'll say well I
believe in gender roles but I also
believe that I should have an education
and that I should have a career and you
know uh if you and then they'll say that
what I'm saying is dangerous right it
always goes back to this programmed fear
of like if we're not equal and if we
don't have control and power of our own
we're going to be abused we're going to
be you know the men will do bad things
to us so we have to we have to be boss
girls and we talk about the Christians
let's say I can only submit to my
husband when he submits to God
[__]
who are you to do is he only gonna love
you when you're acting perfectly
exactly and it's funny because I just
went um I don't want to get any wives in
trouble I don't want to get any so I
won't say where I went to this town and
it was um honestly it was actually
really refreshing to go to this town
because there was a bunch of families
and it was like this company and it was
it was honestly awesome but I I had a
really long drive there and um one guy
drove me and another guy drove me back
that like worked for the company and
they um
they both told me that those Church made
their wives worst wives and they both
had like the on paper like vert like you
know I don't people just open up to me I
don't know but like they told me like
their wives were virgins on their
wedding days and like all this stuff but
like they said the church programming
has made them worse wives
so and yet were the like women's Bible
study they're like like that is the
biggest red flag is what they told yeah
and I was just thinking I'm like
why like the church is supposed to be
where you go to get good wives and I I
would still argue they're probably
depending on the church at least a
little better that you know they're
trying like yeah but what I realized is
like
I wrote this on a paper that the order
of the world and I didn't come to this I
think this is a religious point of view
but I didn't come to this conclusion
from religion like this wasn't but I
just realized I'm like men are better
than us in pretty much every way and God
is better than men in pretty much every
way
and women
are better than children sort I mean
some of the boy ones are pretty smart
you know but yeah
and I'm like yeah so it's like I think
most evil happens
when either man doesn't submit to God
like someone messes up this order seems
to be where evil happens and nowadays
the biggest evil is when women go here
and act like they're equal I don't know
if you can see my paper but but because
that just seems to be where evil happens
because when we get power we're just
kind of bad people
Well I this is probably like one of my
most controversial takes that even a lot
of people who are supposed to be on our
side even a lot of women who probably
agree with 90 of what I say if I go here
that's where you see their little Wall
come up and they're like wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait what you know and
I'm like no and they don't understand
where this came from so this all comes
out of this revolutionary period in the
west from the French Revolution in the
American Revolution where the new idea
is this total rejection of hierarchy
that there shouldn't be a hierarchy that
hierarchies are the problem and the
cause of inequality and if we just get
rid of these man-made hierarchies we'll
all end up equal at some point right
um and that's not what life was like for
all of human existence all of human
history until what 250 years ago which
is a tiny tiny sliver of History it was
never this way because all cultures all
cultures everywhere served hierarchy in
nature so when this revolutionary
thinking happened and you get people
saying no we should all be equal then
that's where you get like uh the crazy
vegan animal rights people because then
they they extrapolate logic and go well
but animals have sentience so animals
should have rights we should extend
human rights to animal rights and
children should be able to consent to
things that we never previously would
have let children consent to and you
know uh women are the same as men and we
shouldn't have that's where you get like
socialism and communism and anarchism
this idea that all authority is bad that
Authority is the problem hierarchy is
the problem and we're going to believe
in this utopian future where everyone
and everything is equal and everyone has
the same and the outcomes are the same
and that is not how things work that is
not how things work and when you try to
do that if you look at the 20th century
the 20th century is a story of democide
meaning governments killing off huge sex
of their population trying to achieve
this nonsense trying to invert the
natural order of things in the natural
hierarchy that you just wrote on the
paper
because this idea of equality sounds
good and especially it sounds good to
women it sounds good to cooked men and
it sounds good to women because
they think to themselves yeah why
shouldn't I be at the top of the
hierarchy right so the cupped men love
it they love egalitarianism because
they're like yeah why is Genghis Khan
getting all the chicks why is why does
the kid you know like why why are the
men at the top of the hierarchy getting
all the women and the resources and the
wives why do they get to be Warlords or
Kings and here I am I'm just cannon
fodder right so on the surface when you
think of it it's like oh that sounds
good so this is why when we say stuff
like women shouldn't vote people are
like why do you hate women why do you
hate them and it's like why does that
mean we hate them it doesn't mean we
hate them but it goes against this idea
everyone's been brainwashed within the
West a egalitarian everything should be
equal everyone's created equal but
that's not true we see that I mean all
you have to do as a little kid is look
around and see some people are much more
attractive some people are taller some
people are stronger some people are
smarter hierarchy exists in the world
and you can't you cannot like this is
where learning philosophy is important
because you learn there is no
possibility of that happening it can't
happen right if you if you ever TR and
if you try to force that a lot of people
end up getting put up against the wall
and shot so or starving to death in
large numbers or getting put in camps or
things like that so well and it's so
funny because you can tell
and this is what I feel like it's like
when I talk you're the only one that
understands when I tweet when I tweet
you're the only one that like
understands what I'm saying nobody else
can like hear me because they just have
this like emotional like gut reaction
you know and they've just never and you
know to be fair like when I first heard
a lot of this stuff like if you asked me
five years ago should you obey your
husband I'd be like what's like obey
yeah like what the [__] I'd be like obey
what what is obey yeah the word obey and
just be like yeah yeah so you know all
conditioning like I understand it too
that's why sometimes I I have to like
sometimes I have to rain in a little bit
and be like Rachel be nice these people
don't know what they don't know right
they they've been conditioned to react
this way from the time they were born
people people in the last 50 years
especially like if you that's why Boomer
women are some of the worst well because
they were so heavily conditioned with
these ideas and they just have a
knee-jerk reaction when they hear a word
like submit when they hear a word like
obey they're like what are you saying
slavery are you saying I should be
abused and you're like no no no no
that's not what we're we're not saying
slavery we're not seeing abuse we're not
saying uh the man should just do
horrible things to you and you're
supposed to say yes sir may I have
another nobody is saying that but we are
saying that you don't fix the wrong
things in the world you don't fix evil
you don't fix bad men by doing what
we've done which is inverting the whole
order and trying to make everything
equal which is why I do like my last sub
step article the last chapter of my book
the book that's coming out next goes
over so much data because at least with
data I can kind of cut through all that
emotional stuff and I can cut through
all the programming and say okay but
look how it's turned out you guys look
at the results women are less safe they
are more abused they are more vulnerable
children are far worse off than they
were under a patriarchy which was
supposed to be bad for children too
right
women aren't doing better women don't
have better lives in a lot of ways I get
like
that's why you have to go through all of
this hard work to correct the history
and to show people the outcomes and be
like look no there's evil in the world
it's a fallen world there's problems
it's not easy no matter what you do but
this is not how you fix it and this is
making it worse not better but people
don't believe that because the
propaganda tells them it's better life
for women used to be horrible women were
slaves they couldn't even read they
weren't allowed to drive or go to school
and like all of that is lies so like
that's why when when you started to
figure out you were like wait a minute
if they lied about this what else are
they lying about right well and even
it's like you can almost tell a chick's
mindset by the words she uses and it's
super it's like that's why when I say
you're using feminist words you're the
only one that understands what I'm
saying because I'll tweet this stuff out
and they're like I'm like partner
feminist word sexual assault feminist
like none of this [__] uh existed before
like the last I don't know when I you
know being completely honest I don't
know when they put it in but it's like
you just know it when you hear it and
it's really interesting too because the
Christian wives you can just tell who
believes in this stuff and who doesn't
when when I when I started tweeting the
stuff about like let me ask my wife yes
and they're all like no you're supposed
to get wisdom from your wife I'm like no
that's look at and I was like maybe I'm
wrong maybe I you know I'm not claiming
I have all the Christian answers but
that doesn't make sense like the wisdom
is supposed to come
God man woman Shield like isn't that Am
I Wrong maybe I'm wrong I don't know so
Tim Gordon who you had on with me when
we did that show on the church being
infiltrated he talks about this a lot
and the whole Catholic World constantly
is trying to ratio this man and he is
correct that's why he he wrote his own
book called the case for patriarchy that
goes over all of the biblical evidence
all the historical evidence in the
Catholic church that no this stuff is
new this stuff was created on purpose by
certain entities that wanted to change
society so you're absolutely right when
you say there's certain terminology that
they developed and this came out of
Marketing okay this came out of
propaganda if anybody out there knows
who Edward Bernays is he's the guy who
kind of invented marketing and
propaganda out of psychology he came
from like the Freud family and he
figured out you know he was the first
one to get women smoking with like
women's smoking campaigns and he was
highly influential in marketing but they
also used all of his research to do
social engineering so they figured out
like in women's studies I'm doing a show
Friday on my Channel about something
called standpoint Theory and this is
another uh way that they like hijack
stuff so they'll they'll take the truth
and they'll go the truth is problematic
and the truth is unfair and the truth
hurts people's feelings and we want
women to be liberated so we're gonna
we're gonna change the terminology like
I just said they'll take um
sterilization and they'll call it women
and girls empowerment right so they'll
take something and just change the
wording to make it sound a certain way
so that it's marketable like Eugenics
was became a bad word so they changed it
to Family Planning right so that this is
how they do it and you can tell as and
this works really well on women because
eighty percent of marketing is aimed at
women because women control most of the
spending so they're very very
susceptible they've got this down to a
fine art it's been a hundred years of
marketing companies studying how to
psychologically influence women with
language with messaging with how they
present certain things out of context to
make them believe certain things are
true
and and this is how it works so you're
right when when you hear Christian wives
even people who think they're
traditional Catholics or traditional
Baptists right and you'll hear them say
stuff like Well when the Bible says the
man's supposed to lead really what that
means is serve and you'll even hear
priests
parroting this stuff because they've
gotten into the seminaries they've
gotten into you know all of the
organizations that control how things
work and they have changed the wording
changed the messaging so what would have
been preached from the pulpit 150 years
ago is not what they're saying now and
they've changed the wording to me well
yes men lead but Christ was the leader
and he served so but Christ said I am
the head of the church Christ is King he
is not
does he serve does he sacrifice yes but
that comes with authority Christ are you
saying Christ does not have authority
over his church yes he does and yes he
says he does so no this idea that Christ
came only to serve and sacrifice and has
no Authority that's not Christian at all
yet that's what we're hearing we're
hearing this and again this goes back to
this idea of like no no men should
sacrifice and serve but they don't have
the authority that would have to come
with that
well and so insane the other thing is
it's like crazy watching the wives
twitch when I say no
your husband doesn't have to ask you
about anything
he doesn't need your permission they're
like
but but Pearl Pearl talk to me when
you're married and I'm like look at it
[__] I don't I gotta stop school but
like I'm like I don't need to be married
to understand the natural order of the
world and they're like Pearl are you
gonna do it perfectly are you gonna
submit and I'm like look it I'm gonna I
am gonna do my best to live by
everything I preach I probably will not
do it perfectly I'm a woman I'm gonna
get my period and go AWOL like like
yeah yeah it's like but if we can't even
admit like this is the goal guys our
goal is to not whine and just obey our
husbands and let him feel like the king
of his own house yeah then how will we
will be improve like maybe I can help
these ladies out because I have been
married for a long time okay
um and
in the beginning of our relationship
things were Rocky and things were not
going so good and I remember having my
Epiphany moment in the shower one day
where I was thinking to myself okay like
I want to figure this out like I want to
make this work why am I having a hard
time and I was at least this is the only
credit I'll give myself was that I was
willing to look at myself first and go
okay is it something I'm doing and I'm
sitting there I'm like shampooing my
hair and I'm thinking to myself okay if
Andrew my husband was the kind of guy
who would roll over and do whatever I
wanted right when we don't agree and he
was like okay honey whatever you say
happy wife happy life would I still
really want him
would I still find him attractive like
is that the kind of guy I want or do I
want the kind of guy that I trust his
leadership so much because he's capable
and you know he's kind like I'm with him
obviously because I think he's a good
guy right so if that's the case why am I
constantly opposing him why am I
constantly like looking for something to
complain about her going yeah he did all
these things well but this one thing you
know he didn't pick up his uh you know
rapper after he ate or he didn't uh take
his shoes off at the you know whatever
stupid little thing it is and I'll zoom
in on that and focus only on that it's
like I kind of just had this Epiphany
where I was like oh if I want a good man
whose leadership I trust then I can't
constantly cut him off at the knees and
oppose him on everything like I have to
let him lead otherwise
my other option is go with one of these
beta cucked guys who is going to roll
over and give me all the power and let
me decide
well we hate them and I know like I knew
I was like you know 25 or something at
this point and even then I was like no I
wouldn't want that I wouldn't want that
because that's a man that you have to
hold his hand and you have to tell him
every little thing he's supposed to do
and then everything is going to be on
you then you are going to be the the one
who has to run everything and you're
also going to hate him and resent him
for that so I was like okay these are
the choices and it seems like picking a
good man with good leadership qualities
and just letting him lead for God's
sakes sounds like a much more peaceful
and better existence and you were right
earlier when you said it's like a weight
lifted off of you it's like a big relief
it's a big relief when you realize like
oh I don't have to run everything I
don't have to always be in charge I
don't have to be the boss I don't have
to fight him and be like well I think
that we should do that like I see wives
do this purely like the man could be be
totally right about something obvious
and she'll still feel the knee-jerk
reaction to oppose him just for the sake
of being like well why should we do what
you say why shouldn't we do something
different what if I want to do something
different well and even because I was on
a show the other day and I was
explaining this
and it's so funny people just look at
you like you're crazy and I'm like look
those I gotta get it but but I was on
this show and they asked me like what
about YouTube Pearl you know so much
about YouTube what if your husband was
in YouTube and didn't want to listen to
your title and he said you should do
this title and I I was just like well
then I just have to go with it and then
you know I think men are logical and
over time if I really had the better
ideas
I think he'd you know men enjoy like
doing things correctly where women will
like run in circles for a lifetime so
it's like you know
um I hope so I'd hope you know
he'd switch it eventually if if I was
right and you know maybe he was right
you know it's like well I mean that's
that's how it works with me and Andrew
and it's not very often but like so
he'll say stuff like like this is how
he'll talk to our daughters about it so
one of our kids has a b allergy okay and
because she has a b allergy and I'm a
nerd I did like all this studying about
like bee allergies and I learned how to
use the EpiPen correctly and I practiced
with it I did all it right because I'm
like worried about it I'm worried
because I'm worried so she we were out
at the pool one day and our dog ran by
and was like snapping at a B and the B
it pissed off the B but instead of
stinging the dog it stung my daughter
who was just right next to the dog so
and she's got like a deathly B allergy
so I just like went into total mom mode
but I stayed super calm and I was like I
was like you call 9-1-1 I'm gonna get
the EpiPen Scarlet you stay right here
and I like I did all this stuff I got
her the benefit a drill I did the EpiPen
we called the ambulance and everything
went fine and my husband was like look
you're I know that your mom is competent
in that sort of thing and so in that
case because I know okay I know that
she's researched this and she's
practicing she knows what to do if she
tells me go call 9-1-1 that's what I'm
gonna do because I already know that
that's something she like that would not
he would not be so irrational as to be
like no I'm the man around here and I
will do the EpiPen no he didn't do that
because why would he because he's
logical enough to be like okay that's a
wife Duty thing and I know my wife is
doing her wife Duty thing so in this
case if she says you call 9-1-1 while I
get the EpiPen I'm just gonna do it
right women get this idea that the men
are gonna be the petty ones who are
gonna like fight us for control on
everything and they're like no if you if
you know how to separate the whites from
the colors and do the laundry like I'm
not gonna fight you on that because
that's a woman thing and you know what
you're doing doing with it right so men
are too busy with their man stuff they
do want you to be competent enough to do
your woman things and they're not going
to fight you on that but what you cannot
do is when it is the man's domain and
his responsibility and it's you know
stuff that he knows and he's like listen
I know you don't agree I know you don't
like my decision but this is what we're
doing there's going to be times where
you're not gonna really like it in that
moment that's true but too bad because
if you were think about it this way if
you were at work and your boss told you
you had to do something and you didn't
agree even if you were like um Mr
Johnson sir I really think based on you
know blah blah that we should do it this
way and he was like I hear you Sally but
we're not doing it we're doing it this
way you might Grumble but you're gonna
do it if a police officer pulls you over
and says ma'am you were going 10 over
the speed limit back there and you think
you were only going for over you might
be like well it looked like I was only
going for it but he's like nope my my
radar gun says it was 10 here's your
ticket you're not gonna like fight him
but we will fight our husbands we don't
fight other authority but we're willing
to fight our husbands over like what to
have for lunch it's crazy well and it's
like okay guys guys
so you're telling me you're gonna obey
a stranger who you work for
but you will not obey let me get this
straight the person you decided to make
a child with
and it's like okay who are you dating
where like I was like who do you guys
expect me to date where he wouldn't
listen to me about a YouTube title right
you don't even like do you think that
there's guys that are this like die hard
and that like they're just like yes
Pearl now that we're dating I am here
I'm taking over yeah I'm taking over
your YouTube title like of all the
things I'm like you know if you're gonna
take over something like I just I
wouldn't think it would be the title
it's so funny because when this book
came out I had all these people who said
she didn't write the book her husband
wrote the book and just told her to put
her name on it and this and that so that
he wouldn't get in trouble he was the
one behind it he filled her head with
all these ideas he told her all the and
my husband's response to this was I
don't know what she's doing I'm busy
with man [__] like if she wants to write
some book about girl stuff like whatever
he was just kind of like yeah good for
her she wrote a good book Good Wife good
job but he was just like I don't I don't
give a [__] about what she's doing I'm
busy like I'm not
I have no time to sit there and like
tell her to write a book about some
feminist nonsense you know what I mean
so he was just like why do people think
that I'm some Tyrant who has all this
time on my hands to just like
micromanage your every move he always
said that he's like I don't know she's
off doing woman stuff I don't know what
she's doing
because he's busy so yeah yeah like guys
aren't really dying
to hear about the history of feminism
all the time they're kind of like beer
football
sex that's like you know they're like
yeah yeah that's exactly how how it is
so sometimes I come in the room and I'll
be like oh my gosh honey you're not
gonna believe this crazy thing I found
about this feminist in the 1800s and
he's just like uh-huh
[Music]
sometimes well sometimes he'll be like
honey I love you but I'm busy could you
just shut up
and I I know that women will be like oh
my God abusive he's a narcissist but no
he's just like honey I it might look
like I'm just doing whatever on my phone
but I'm actually like setting up a
debate or I'm doing whatever so he'll
just be like honey I love you but can
you just be quiet because I'm busy
I had a boyfriend tell me once I like
came up to him and I was telling him
this like you know something that you
know how it is you find something you're
excited about on the internet and he's
and you're like I'm so excited and then
he's just like
yeah yeah but to me like if you can
learn to just kind of laugh that off and
be like okay because let's be honest
women when your husband's talking about
his fantasy football league do you care
no when he's talking about his latest
hunting rifle he just got or the new
tires he chose for his truck that he has
all the fancy stuff you don't care about
that but we have this perception that if
men don't pretend to care about every
little thing we say that they like don't
love us he didn't care but this is one
of the top reasons women cite for
Divorce by the way is he's not
emotionally invested enough in me which
to me I know what they're saying you can
use all your coded language I know what
that means that means when I'm prattling
on about my woman nonsense he doesn't
pretend to be interested enough and it
hurts my feelings it's like he's not
gonna care just like you don't care
about his stuff and you don't feel bad
about that yeah and that's the thing I'm
like guys listen to our [__] way more
than we listen to their [__] yeah and
what I what I've also realized is like
we don't really for whatever reason we
just only think about the stuff we do
and don't think about the stuff they do
and I've realized I'm like you know if
you're in a relationship and you feel
like you did more you probably didn't
yeah and well this is a good pro-wife
tip from me to you younger ladies out
there this is another big mistake I made
that I think a lot of women make early
on which is and my husband finally
figured out how to like articulate this
to me and at first I I did what all of
us do and I was like no I don't I don't
do that I don't do that but I did so if
he were to come home and actually like
you know he comes home and he's in a
crummy mood and I'm like what's wrong
and he's like nothing he doesn't want to
tell me right he's like nothing I'm fine
I just just had a cranky day at work and
I'd be like no what's the matter what's
the matter what's the matter finally he
would tell me like oh there's this guy
at work and he's just giving me issues
he's just really difficult to work with
and it really like I I could have gotten
injured today because this guy was being
a dick and blah blah and he's telling me
about it then I would turn it into my
problem I would make it about me because
I'd be like well now I'm worried that
you're gonna get hurt when you go to
work and what if you lose your job and
then what are we gonna do you know like
I would turn it into something about me
and he was trying to tell me this and I
was so adamant like no I don't I don't
do that I don't do that
but you know a few days go by and I'm
thinking about it and then I couldn't
unsee it right then I couldn't unsee how
if he ever did voice and he'd say look
you're a woman that's what you're gonna
do but that's why I don't want to tell
you about it okay I'll vent to my guy
friends I'll I'll tell my dad or
something else but I'm not gonna tell
you everything because you're just gonna
turn it into like your worries and then
now not only do I have to deal with the
guy at work but now I have to like
console you and calm your fears about me
losing my job or quitting my job or
getting her or whatever so that's
another thing that we women can't really
help this to a certain extent we kind of
almost have to unlearn this because we
process everything through our emotions
men don't really do that because from
the time they're little that's not what
life's about for them it's about like uh
what they can produce how they can prove
that they can be contribute to the
hierarchy like men have a whole
different outlook on life from the time
they're very little than we do and we
process everything through how it makes
me feel and how she would feel if I said
it to her and like this kind of stuff
which is good for when you're a mom and
it's good for when you're with your
girlfriends but when it comes to your
husband this is why it has to be the
hierarchy that it is this is why we
can't just constantly expect men to like
understand it from our perspective and
listen to what we're saying and take our
advice and don't you care what I think
about stuff and why aren't you listening
to what I think we should do because of
that fundamental difference that you
can't do anything about and it's always
going to be like that so if you're going
to task your husband with all the
responsibility he has to have the
authority to go along with it and you'll
hear people say that's not how my
marriage is I'm so glad my marriage
isn't that way me and my husband are
equal Partners in everything and I'm
like no he's just not telling you he's
not going to tell you all of his like
fears and worries and this and that
because he knows you're just gonna make
it all about yourself so he lets you
believe there's this equal partnership
so that you'll shut the [__] up right so
that you'll be quiet and he can have
peace but they really think that and
there's a whole generation of just
shitty wives
God and it's so sad because in all
honesty
there are so few wives that actually
believe this you can't even see it in
the whatever because what happens to us
when we say that what happens what do we
get from women we get you hate you're a
self-hating woman you hate other women
you have Stockholm syndrome uh it's not
my fault that you're stupid and can't do
anything for yourself but I'm a strong
independent woman I don't need a man to
tell me what to do we just get like [__]
all over if we say hey I I observe this
natural hierarchy and I'm going to
respect it because my life is better and
my family's life is better and things
work when I do that we get told that we
get called horrible things we get called
names we get told we're ugly we
consultant like that we're just the
worst so well and this whole generation
of just like shitty wives to be honest
has just given all of us such bad advice
like I send you the tick tock the other
day um
I'm like
oh no no don't do that I would say
ladies look at this is what I would say
all right you're you're 15 you're like
thinking about Dayton I'm like looking
stay a virgin until 22. you will be the
most sought after like you will have a
line of proposals yes you know make it
through well I would I would say don't
even go to college but I'm like go you
know do your thing at 22 you can date a
32 year old you can date a 35 year old
so if you wanna you know it's like do
most 19 year olds want to date like a 35
year old no but at 22 you might kind of
find them hot and you can marry Rich you
can marry your
um ambition you can marry whoever you
want yes
we actually stay in shape
you know tell our daughters this like
this is our advice to them my husband
and this is like a good dad everyone you
people who are crazy and think that like
I have some kind of awful husband my
husband is the best which is why he gets
hot breakfast and I don't give him any
[__] because I know that I got lucky
and kind of I'm punching above my weight
here you guys I got really lucky so I
respect it but he will sit down his
daughters and say look you are beautiful
you are worth a lot you have so you're
gonna be a valuable mother someday you
know you've had a mother teach you how
to be a mother you know how to be a good
wife you are a good Christian girl and
you have your virginity those are your
like big assets so if a guy is six foot
tall and he has six pack abs and he's
got an engineer's brain and like a
masters in engineering those are all his
assets these are your assets don't just
give them away to some idiot down the
street three don't give it away to some
dude who lives in a trailer park like
don't be giving away your best assets
because he cares about them and he's
like I want you to have the best choice
to pick the best man who's going to give
you the best future this is how you do
that right that's good parenting that's
a good fathering and so our daughters
have this massive advantage and but
nowadays women will act like that's bad
like we are like I've had horrible
comments from people being like your
children are gonna ghost you and never
speak to you again they're gonna hate
you for raising them like it's the
Middle Ages you know all this crazy
stuff and oh no that's great advice
that's great like it's like they're
gonna have their pick of the litter you
know I mean it is tough because it's
like I know men don't want to get
married nowadays but like
I know
there are men messaging me all the time
where can I find Divergence I'm like
good luck
get the same thing I get the same thing
too well but what I will say to that
like men will message me and or they'll
comment on my stuff and they'll be like
where can I find a woman like you and
I'm like well first of all I was not
born this way I was raised by a Marxist
feminist crazy woman and even though I
knew she was wrong like I never went I
never fully went feminist at all even
when I was young I still was raised in
this culture and I still had all her
programming and the effects of being
raised by a single crazy feminist mom
who intentionally kept my dad away as
much as possible so I screwed up a lot
of things and I had to learn so like I
didn't come out of the womb like this I
had to do a lot of work on myself to
become a good wife and to become a good
mom and I think most women have to do
that now most of us come from broken
families most of us had crummy moms and
even crummy grandmas a lot of us uh we
you know we grew up surrounded by
Beyonce and Taylor Swift and all this
strong girl programming and
it's not women's fault that they don't
know these things but that's why what
you're doing is important that's why I'm
doing what I'm doing because I thought
about like the Legacy I was leaving my
four daughters and I thought what if out
of the four daughters I have like 12
granddaughters you know like there could
be all these girls and like I don't want
them to not figure it out I don't want
them to take until they're 28 to figure
it out like I did you know and make
mistakes along the way that they can't
reverse so that's why I do this stuff so
with the leadership of Good Men you can
turn women around but I know it's not
easy and I know I'm not saying men are
obligated to like adopt a 304 because
she reformed okay like that was the
thing on Twitter I was like I am in no
way saying that high value men are
obligated to wife some girl because she
oh I used to ride the dick Carousel and
now I'm reformed so now you have to
marry me no no I'm not saying that they
don't deserve that but I am saying we're
kind of in a crisis here like all the
women are brought up this way all the
women are raised in this culture so
it's hard to they don't just good wives
aren't just born you have to make them
into good ones yeah well and for me it
was like I kind of got red pilled on
camera so I started like reacting to
stuff it was like two two and a half
years ago before the show even started I
started reacting to like pick up and
like fresh and fit and all those guys
and Kevin like Kevin Samuels I'm a huge
fan of I I called him a douchebag the
first time I saw him like sweet I
thought I thought he was because I
realized I'm like our whole lives we
have never heard men talk in a masculine
way because they're always altering
their speech for us so when we first
hear this stuff we're like
or like what do you mean like this this
you know but it's kind of like I I had
to like start to program myself to stop
having a gut reaction and ask first is
this true right and if it's true like um
I think he said are are do modern women
want to be victims or do women today
want to be victims and I'm like me Andy
we want to be Victor this is before I
did the show now I understand completely
what he was saying but and then I
thought about it and I'm just like
we do we kind of do all of our music is
like Taylor Swift and I think it also
shows like what music is really popping
off now it's all for the women it's all
heartbreak it's all sad yeah and it's a
lot of like revenge porn songs in fact
I'm gonna do a stream with uh my friend
who's a literature guy who analyzes Like
lyrics and poetry and stuff we're gonna
do a show about like the vengeful witchy
Breakup Song phenomenon like all of like
think of the Carrie Underwood song where
she catches a guy cheating so she
destroys his car
that's insane but people like you go
girl right yeah if you catch him I can't
lie to you I do like that song it's a
bob everybody
came out with a
where he caught a woman cheating and
like burned her house down or something
people would be like you are in prison
you know Olivia Rodrigo too like that's
who blew up and it's like
I don't even remember it's like driver's
license
oh yeah
but it was some victim song it was
something yeah it's always like the man
did me wrong now I'm gonna get his I'm
gonna get his ass I'm gonna show him I'm
gonna do this I wanna write an album
called I was wrong and I'm gonna call it
and I'm gonna have all the stories of
either some some could be me you know
but some it's like just chicks on the
show
like I'm sorry do you remember two years
ago when the [__] song Megan the stallion
and cardi B did that [__] song a whole
song about the power you have from your
Vijay and I was just like this is so
like it would have never been allowed on
the radio 20 years ago 30 years ago
probably but now there's like moms
listening to it with their teenage
daughters and being like you know bump
into it and whatever and I'm like ah no
and then we go why are all the women
crazy and it's like well well even the
song I remember the song You Know
whistle that song yeah I didn't know it
was about in high school when it came
out yeah I was like singing it and
someone was like you know what that's
about right I'm like no
yeah so a lot of it is very sneaky a lot
of it's very sneaky and there's so I
mean think about just the Taylor Swift
phenomena people love Taylor Swift women
love I've never that's my biggest Flex
my biggest Flex is I've never liked
Taylor Swift ever uh but a lot of women
do tons of women do she sells out every
single Arena she goes to and a large
number of her songs are breakup anthems
about how the guy ain't [__] and she's
too good for him anyway and he just
didn't know what he had and all this
kind of stuff so it's like
and this has been going on a long time
like Madonna's music was this way like a
lot of the female pop stars pretty much
all of them are like sexual empowerment
female empowerment themed artists and
it's so sad like I watch Taylor Swift's
interviews from like 10 like 15 years
ago and she's just this cute girl yeah
but it's like when you're told you're a
victim for 10 years you kind of evolve
into something else and that's why this
stuff's important to be honest because
again when we just believe we're victims
we're kind of terrible people and if he
she's a victim of the the the syndrome I
always talk about pretty girl syndrome
if you were a pretty girl and then
especially if you're Taylor Swift like
she had massive success at a very young
age she was like 16 or something when
she really broke out so she's always
since you know since she's been a
teenager been
in control of a lot of money she's her
own little economy right she's got tons
of money tons of power more attention
than almost any female on planet Earth
right so of course from her world view
she's gonna be like see everywhere I go
these men just ain't [__] I'm just too
good for all of them I'm gonna you know
it's like these younger girls that are
really attractive and they build their
whole world view off of everybody wants
me I'm super valuable I'm the BET like
it kind of really screws them up and
that's how they end up like these
vengeful crazy feminists when they get
older and a lot of that starts to go
away because they hit the wall or
whatever right so well it's
kind of crazy too because social media
makes every girl a celebrity
and it's like before you know the
peasant's wife wouldn't have access to
the king you should never meet him so
she'd be happy and but it's like we get
access to these guys that we would never
in a million years have access to and
you would just marry Jim Bob down the
road and you're like all right he's not
you know because we find like 80 percent
of men is ugly but he like makes you
laugh or whatever and then all of a
sudden like if things are cool but it's
like now because you know we have so
many choices
one the men the men are kind of like we
don't we don't want you guys anyway
I know it's like I think like 60 or 70
of men under 30 aren't even looking for
a relationship so the men are walking
away anyway but then it's like we also
live in this delusion that we can get
the top 10 percent of guys
and the truth is
um unless you're maybe a seven or higher
you have a shot I'll give the I'll give
the sevens just because everyone's fat
nowadays so it's like in a war so
you know but really no it's not really
in the cards for you but we're just told
we should have everything and you're a
queen and your prince charming is coming
and you gotta kiss a lot of frogs to get
a prince it's like [__] you're not
getting a prince no you're giving the
baker down the road you know my great
grandma you can see this so much this is
why like your show the whatever podcast
fresh and fit these girls go on and you
ask them to rate themselves and all of
them think they're a 10.
which even to me because I was born in
1980 I'm like
what now right and I think back to when
I was growing up like in the 80s we had
baggier clothes everybody wasn't naked
all the time everything wasn't as
sexualized as it is now and I don't ever
remember thinking about what my butt
looked like until I was like 20. which
is wild now because now that's all that
matters that's all that matters to women
is what their ass looks like it's like
your whole personality is your ass and
it so it's like a whole it's a whole
different world and these girls growing
up on social media hearing lizzo talk
about how she's lizzo calls herself body
goals and these young girls grow up
watching this and like yeah that's right
I'm body goals so they every woman
thinks she's a 10 which is so insane
it's just so crazy have you noticed and
I was thinking about this I think
they're making the people in media and
on TV and in movies uglier I think so
too they're getting because when is the
last like Megan Fox we've had
I can't think of anyone they pick
intentionally I was just saying this on
Twitter yesterday all these actresses
that their eyes are like 10 people I'm
just like what is this and then you see
like Bebe rexa Christina Aguilera girls
that 10 years ago had like really nice
bodies in really good shape
they are getting so big
these girls are like babies
oh you haven't seen her oh girl I'm
gonna google this be quiet she's three
times the size she used to be and I
literally said I know that people think
I'm a conspiracy theorist already but I
was like are they paying them to get
bigger because why are they going on
stage like if you look at Bebe Rex's
Instagram
oh my gosh
yeah they are blowing up they're all
getting huge and I'm like are they doing
this on purpose
yeah it's insane they don't it's
well it's like okay it's they're
supposed to be unrealistic beauty
standards yeah like I'm supposed to look
at these chicks and feel a little bad
about myself yeah I miss even when I saw
Victoria's Secret
um and they made Tom Brady's wife the
cover I'm like she's 40. I don't feel
that like you know yeah you know but I'm
like it's supposed to be I'm 26. that
should be the oldest woman in that
magazine yeah at most really after 25
you should be done and and like I'm like
put the hot 18 19 20 22 year olds
that'll make me feel a little bad about
myself and give me something I can put
on my fridge to run towards yes exactly
well but see I I don't think that that
was as bad people love to talk about
like oh there was such such unrealistic
beauty standards in the 80s and 90s and
I showed my daughters like the 90s
supermodels like Cindy Crawford and
Nikki Taylor and like Linda Evangelista
and they were like oh my God these women
are gorgeous they my daughters were like
whoa they're like so hot and this was
before everything was like filtered they
would do photo retouching but you can go
watch videos of them on runways and they
were hot and now the women that they
tell us are like the tens like the girl
in the Snow White movie and the girl
from The Little Mermaid movie and some
of these people they're like they're
cropping up yeah you're like but she's a
six or a seven you know like
you're telling me that this is the ideal
there should I mean what's wrong with
having an ideal what's wrong with
picking the handful of women that are
the most beautiful and going wow look at
them they're the ideal and we all knew
like I knew growing up in the 80s and
90s I'm not gonna be a supermodel okay
I'm five foot six and I'm like a average
girl next door looking person but I was
fine with that because I knew that
modeling was for models but nowadays
every girl thinks she needs to be an
Instagram model so then everybody throws
a temper tantrum about unrealistic
beauty standards it's like when I was
growing up it was like all of us knew we
were just gonna like find a nice guy and
get married and that was going to be our
life we didn't all think we were gonna
be famous well and the other thing too I
was thinking about was that
you know so they they put in the uglier
models and I was thinking about how like
I watched a movie or something from like
20 years ago and I just couldn't believe
how beautiful the whim I think it was
like mean girls with Lindsay Lohan yeah
and it was like Lindsay Lohan and The
Four Chicks that starred in it and I was
like they all had a very different type
of beauty yeah and now it's like even
Lindsay Lohan's face now just looks like
every other chick because she's put in
the botox the lip filler yeah and it's
like it almost ruins like
you know it would kind of be beautiful
where you'd have one beautiful chick
with a little bit big of a forehead and
one beautiful chick with eyes a little
too far apart not like they're great
yeah or like the thin lips and one with
big lips and one with kind of a but they
were all like beautiful but now it's
like they've all gotten nose jobs
they've all put in the lip filler yeah
they go to the same plastic surgeon and
come out of the assembly line looking
exactly the same and yeah like my friend
Jamie hanshaw does a bunch of research
on psyops and things like that and she's
talked about how that's intentional and
she'll go back and look at like there
was a Lady Gaga concert from 10 years
ago at an award show where she actually
comes out of an assembly line like out
of a factory that makes a bunch of
Gaga's or whatever and so it's like some
a lot of this is culture creation and
the CIA did culture Creation in the 60s
and 70s with the Congress for cultural
Freedom with operation Mockingbird they
had like multiple programs to create and
promote the culture that we have now so
there is some intentional stuff people
think it's just marketing or it's just
money but that's not exactly true they
there is something more to it than that
where they are trying to engineer stuff
and it goes along with this propaganda
and all the stuff we've been talking
about so there is that I mean like Jay
Dyer is great on all that stuff he's got
like hundreds of videos talking about it
so there is an element of that
but what we're dealing with now is just
so crazy which is the other reason why
people you and I did a show about how
yeah you can afford kids but women will
be like no I can't I need ten thousand
dollars a month just to keep up my
eyelash extensions my nails my lip
fillers my new Birkin bag that I need
every season like all this crazy stuff
that women think they need
it
when I went on that show in Miami they
were like how much does it cost to
maintain you and I'm just like
you're like maintain me
I was just thinking I'm like I probably
make more than all these [__] and I
had a lower number I was like I don't
know like
I think I said two grand and I felt like
that was high like I I think because
they are like 10 10 I'm like I don't
know to like I like to get my nails done
and drink coffee every day yeah that's
like what is that what is that called I
do my nails myself to save the money but
it's like I do my own hair to save the
money I do everything I did go to
Cosmetology School see this is what we
do with our big giant genius brain Pearl
as women we take our genius brain and we
get a cosmetology license
um but no as like I don't I just buy a
purse from like a regular store and I
use it yeah I go to Target and then I
use it until there's like a hole in it
or like the strap brace or something
but that's how I can have five kids
right because I'm not sinking thousands
of dollars into all this crazy upkeep
I'm like okay I should go to the gym and
work out and try to not be a giant whale
and I should probably like you know do
my hair and put on some mascara but my
husband doesn't want to invest 10 grand
a month and getting me plumped and
tucked and filled and you know all this
crazy stuff he just looks like it's a
vanity too like that used to be a sin I
think yeah it'll yeah yeah I was I was
thinking because there's mirrors in here
and I was like I don't think we're meant
to see ourselves this much no like with
the phones and like the screen I'm like
I think we're not supposed to look at
our faces this much yeah well I was also
saying because I'm the world's least
photogenic person I look terrible I take
terrible every picture of me is me going
because you don't like dying no no no I
want to defend this right now you don't
have time to learn all the poses and the
Angles and all of this [__] that all
these other women have spent like a
million years figuring out how to learn
because you got better [__] to do I
remember like 10 years ago when people
used to take bad pictures and everyone's
were bad yeah there's no posing nobody
knew how to do that it was just take a
selfie
yeah I don't know anything about that
and it's like I'm not saying I'm oh I'm
a 10 in real life but it's like I look
as there's really bad pictures of me
floating around and people will be like
you're ugly you're ugly and I told my
husband I was like I never heard I was
ugly until I started doing this so what
do you think is more rational that I
went 40 years never hearing anyone call
me ugly and then suddenly I get on the
internet and everyone's just like you're
ugly you're ugly or ugly and I'm just
like okay well but you're right it's
because I don't use a bunch of filters I
don't have veneers like I don't people
have fake teeth they have fake
everything they got fake hair they got
fake eyelashes Botox fillers all this
stuff guys I'm just like a Midwestern
housewife I was like if you were
expecting an Instagram model sorry to
disappoint you
but like why would I even do that it's
so weird but it's you know what life is
better when you're just not
trying to do all that like you're not
even living these women who have all
this they don't even worry you need to
like spend two hours getting ready I
could never
I just have better things to do with my
time I take 20 minutes to get ready for
doing this and I'm like
rushing through it I've gotten a lot
better do something I've gotten a lot
better since I've done media but like
you know sometimes I just look in the
mirror and I don't like I'll think I
look old or I don't like my makeup or
whatever and I'm just like I'm not
supposed to see my face this much I
thought I was thinking about this I'm
like I'm not even really supposed to
know what I look like they're just
supposed to be like a water bin that I
can kind of see an outline
well now we are see this is me and pearl
women prattling we are woman paddling
but I think it's purposeful woman
prowling yeah but I do I I had a great
time having you on I learned something
new as usual
um I I'm gonna I gotta hand it to you
you were like an encyclopedia you know
you are I would say you're the smartest
woman online woman though not man no I'm
definitely not the smartest man online
I'm definitely not like
people ask me who like like who my
heroes are most of them are men because
like Jay Dyer would be like one of my
primary mentors because I love his work
and I think that if I could leave a body
of work behind like he's got someday of
like the stuff I've studied that would
be amazing and now that's not gonna
happen because I'm not a man and I have
to cook breakfast and raise kids and
hopefully I'll be a grandma soon but you
know in my little spare time this is
what I do and I have fun doing it I love
doing it I'm a little bit nerdy and this
is what you know some women go to the
club that's not what I do I'm like
whoops dig up some old historical
archives and go through them I know what
you mean it's like I could go out or
hear me out I could
research this random person from the
feminist movement right exactly because
I'm just curious and I want to know and
but Pearl does it too all the time
because she'll just text me and be like
what's going on with this because this
seems off and she's usually onto
something she always knows like her
brain just knows when she looks at
something and she's like that don't seem
right to me I feel like something's
going on here and she almost always I
decided I'm done looking at studies
they're just there to confuse me
[Laughter]
women are not smarter than men no IQ
test can convince me we're the Dumber
ones
but that's okay you know if you want to
be a good mom be a good mom be a PL you
know this this was the thing that
everyone got advice on in like the 1800s
when we look at like the wife manuals
from the 1800s it was like basically
just be pleasant make the room a nicer
room to be in because you're there or
make the home nicer it be the kind of
woman that when you're around people go
well I love when she's around it's just
so nice to have her run because she's
just like I like her
that's good enough you don't have to be
the man and you don't have to be as
smart as the men and you don't have to
be an engineer and you don't have to run
a business and be a CEO you can just be
a nice lady who raises good kids and
everybody will appreciate you it's
enough
yeah that's what I think or you can just
have it all do everything
yeah where's my where's my shoulder pads
in my pantsuit
yeah yeah well Rachel pleasure as always
you know we gotta make this like uh like
every other week thing or something
because you're you're awesome they love
you on here well thanks Pearl and thanks
Pearl's audience I wasn't sure if you
guys would enjoy all of my nerd facts
but I'm glad that people had such a good
response to the the big one we did
everybody seemed really like that so
thanks everybody for supporting me well
guys
um let me know what you think in the
comments you know what do you what do
you think did the sexual Revolution was
it a good thing did we just are are
women like super happy today or no I
don't know just let me let me know
um guys make sure you go follow Rachel
on Twitter
um I retweet her all the time so if you
follow me at some point
um you should you should post clips from
this on Twitter I will I'm gonna I'm
gonna try to be a better businesswoman
Pearl I promise she's like trying to
drag me she's like not too good don't
you can you can no but I will retweet it
you know so like the video guys on your
way out follow her on Twitter
um YouTube Instagram all of her links
are gonna be in the description so
you'll find them there subscribe to the
channel we're trying to get to two mil
before the end of the year I hit one
mill last year my goal
um it was so funny I I wanted to hit a
million by the first and I think I hit
it like either the day after the first
or like like the second I was really
close so this year I'm like let me get
two million by the end of this year so
subscribe to the channel like the video
on your way out and I'll talk to you
next time